[Music]
damian i was going to ask you did do you
think the internet can be a creative
space again or do you think when we got
rid of the lsd and the ecstasy in the
mid 90s the creativity that was being
put into the internet also got possibly
comment on the la on the latter question
but
you know anders you seem to be getting
dangerously close to saying that we have
to choose between regulation and
innovation
no i think we need a regulation that
managed to leave things open-ended and
that's tricky it's very tricky it's very
very tricky
and
which is why this next stage where we're
deciding what is the competition
framework and what this online harms uh
framework is very very dangerous you
know we've got a kind of a gang of
conservative mps
making a pact with free expression
campaigners to try and shoot this bill
down because they think it's killing
freedom of expression you know just you
know i would observe that there's plenty
of regulation in china there's also a
huge amount of innovation
so i don't think it's a direct choice
and for online harms and the the the
legislation
here
um
there's a lot of work to be done i think
what the government has done
is create a piece of legislation where
it's there are too many dangers of
censorship in there so the secretary of
state can meddle in lots of ways with
ofcom ofcom is our independent regulator
that has to be completely independent
from government by the way and we need
to watch that it is and stop governments
meddling with it they've done a both uh
the the current government and the
former government have been far too
involved in ofcom ofcom is now going to
be uh responsible for working directly
with the platforms
to create codes of practice and define
things like what is harmful what is to
be considered harmful content
and also
all sorts of different categorizations
of what is journalistic content and
therefore exempt and what is
democratically useful content so that is
quite close to this question of the
chinese view of protecting social
harmony
through regulation so we've got to look
at this very very carefully and we've
got to
ensure that
no government let alone this government
is able to use this system of regulation
as a way of controlling public opinion
so there's a there's a really subtle
balance to be struck between protecting
against harms and capture by by
politicians and special interests i mean
isn't a good test of that um whether or
not the internet within any regulatory
framework is still capable of voice
giving voice to dissent so could the
hour of spring have happened without the
internet
yes but did it happen quicker was the
means to communication was the means for
activists to share information about
where to go what to say and what could
be said what might not be said was that
easy because the internet also yes but
people could still have demonstrated now
i think that if we allow a framework
where dissent is not tolerated where
dissent is crushed that's really
problematic for democracy itself and
you're absolutely right-handers about
this sort of urge of governments to want
to protect the harmony but i i mean i
actually think politicians should be
brave enough to want to welcome dissent
the thing that we sometimes get caught
up in is when does dissent become abuse
when does it become harm i find it
really problematic and i say it as a
politician i find it really problematic
when politicians decide that they are
the ones to decide what is harmful
whether it's in a democracy or a
dictatorship i find that really really
problematic but the very nature of
independent regulators is that we the
politicians set the things up so we
still have that inherent tension but the
more power we give to independent
regulators to be able to come up with
well-reasoned opinions over what is
harmful and how we manage that the
better i think and politicians have got
to be unafraid to welcome the chaos and
the the the the lack of protection for
the status quo that will inevitably
bring i think that's really important i
mean i actually use the internet to do
democracy in the last year we did our
democracy on zoom i hated it by the way
but we did do it i've also used um the
internet to run my campaigning sessions
things that we just used to do by
knocking on a door and saying hello my
name is thank you now i want to talk to
you about the labour party i can now do
on zoom i can do it via an online tool
that the labour party has that allows me
to connect with voters allows me to
capture information
of a certain degree i can't capture
everything but i can capture certain
things and i don't get to decide i
shouldn't get to decide when to limit
that for other political parties or
other activists or other campaigners it
should be a means of of democracizing
campaigns on facebook
i personally don't because i'm really
bad at it um i don't really understand
social media i'm really bad at it but i
know other people who possibly do but
i've not done that but just super
quickly like one of the stupid mistakes
we've made and it's technically
difficult is that we have these spaces
online we just make almost no attempt to
replicate the rules we have other
campaigning so political campaigning
right if you get leaflet through your
door it's got to by law tell you who
it's published by in the name and
address of the agent doesn't apply to
online political advertising so it's
just it's in the elections builder it is
now yeah yeah but like so
but
now
it's a catch-up thing isn't it and of
course there's also then almost no
enforcement because whilst you know some
of these platforms have enabled
political advertising for you to trace
who it's going to
it's quite easy to navigate it's not all
the platforms there's efforts going on
this right like it's not it's not this
is not a new point but it is this sort
of madness where we we think oh online
it's so special and freedom of speech
instead of thinking we've talked about
this for a really long time and come up
with a regulatory settlement about what
politicians should do or i don't know
the idea of like what advertising kids
should be able to see and and so we just
we just don't even bother with it when
it comes to the internet i mean this is
why i think we should have that
rebuttable principle if it's illegal
offline or it needs to be regulated
offline we should have some sort of
baseline which is we start from here for
the online world and then work out
whether or not we depart from it and how
we do it let's engage in a little bit of
future gazing starting with you and it's
sam burke because really the question
needs to be what is it you guys actually
want what do you want to see and in 30
seconds if we all can please give it a
30 seconds anders what would your ideal
internet look like a global brain
but
in fact a brain actually
consists of a lot of little modules that
are not always playing along with each
other quite a lot of them compete with
each other but you want to make sure
that you actually help the good side
which is coordinating people on a
massive scale and spreading information
widely
can work well
but that requires internal filtering and
damping systems that need to be adaptive
and this is very abstract but
unfortunately that is part of why it's
so darn hard to regulate
and polly you've got two wonderful
children running around the festival at
the moment what is three wonderful
children there's one missing
one of them is a bit weird
i mean what sort of internet do you want
them internet environment i guess do you
want them to grow up in well so i mean
at demos we talk about the the good web
project which we're running and
for me like a lot of it is really just
trying to translate all the complex
detailed understanding we have about
what makes communities work and actually
build that into essentially system
design around around platforms and
communities we know so much about what
makes people kind to one another how
people operate well together and we see
communities online that are fantastic
with open source community for example
or
github which i do not understand but i
like wikipedia like there are there are
glorious bits of cooperation and mutual
benefit on the internet and actually we
need instead of just always thinking
about like let's chop off the bottom 10
is actually how you make the second
quartile and third quartile as good as
as good as the top
well damian i'm going to give you your
opportunities to do your best john perry
imbala
i'm not getting i'm not going there john
perry barlow was mad
[Laughter]
the um
the ideal internet we can learn a lot
from history here you know in in
broadcasting at least we had a plurality
of different kind of ownership and
accountability models so we had
broadcasters that had lots of licensing
requirements and had to really look
after people and and do what's right for
the public interest and meet very high
standards
um and we had um
other broadcasters that were that had
lower standards um
what we didn't have is have uh and i
think we should have online is community
ownership trust ownership and charity
ownership and we need to have uh more
different kinds of models but the
legislative initiatives are really
trying to shape
the future internet so the kind of
services you use in 10 years time
may well be quite different because of
the choices that we're taking as
societies so
it may be
that we are not locked into just a few
social media platforms which are
basically advertising monopolies it may
be that they have been shrunk and that
people have been given data portability
for example um enforced under the gdpr
so that we can take our data share it
with other platforms and switch more
seamlessly between between services
it may be
that there has been forms of different
different kinds of forms of investment
which enable um
services to be launched by other uh
players than than large corporations
um but i think what's really important
is that where whichever spaces we occupy
online we know what the rules are and we
know what to expect so if we want to go
to a tough and dangerous place we go in
with our eyes open and the rules we know
are going to be enforced and that they
do what they say on the tin and if we
want or we want our kids to use other
environments
terms of service are enforced
harmful content is taken down if we
don't want to be racially abused we know
we will not be racially abused in those
those places it takes
public decision making to
make that internet and we're trying to
develop these policy tools but it's
going to take some time
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas